welcome back mother nature can cause
havoc at a moment's notice
in fact there was a 4.2 earthquake near
lake tahoe earlier today
well may is building safety month and
week 4 focuses on disaster preparedness
the code council wants to help everyone
protect their home
advance planning for devastating events
helps protect the health
and safety of all of us when natural
disaster strikes
therefore one of the best ways for
communities to prepare for any threat
is to build to the most up-to-date
building codes
the international code council is the
leading developer of the most widely
used
and highly regarded set of building
safety codes and standards in the world
to construct safe sustainable and
affordable structures
studies show strong code enforcement
decreases loss
following disasters by up to 25 percent
so what should you do
if considering retrofitting your home
keep in mind the potential natural
dangers for your area and secure the
proper permits
from your local building department
should a disaster happen
develop a family action plan so you'll
know where to go if you need to evacuate
review at least two exit routes to a
designated meeting place create a
disaster supply kit
and stay tuned to radio tv and noaa
weather radio for life saving updates
for more visit buildingsafetymonth.org